RICK: What do we got here?
I have brought you in
something that you may want
to take home and use tonight.
A bar of soap from 1896.
RICK: Yellow Kid Soap.
That is funny.
And, uh, yeah, it
definitely looks aged.
It's seen its better days.
[laughs]
MAN: I came in the
pound shop today
to sell my Yellow Kid soap.
It was an early comic
strip character.
He wore a yellow nightgown
with different saying on it.
And it was real politically
geared at the time.
If I sold the bar
of soap today, I'd
probably make sure my daughter
has a very nice birthday.
It's really, really
neat and different.
It was, like, the first
comic strip to really use,
like, the bubbles that come up.
But everything he said
was written on his shirt.
It was really weird.
The reason they
called him Yellow Kid,
he was always wearing
a yellow nightshirt.
His actual name
was Mickey Dugan.
He was a little boy that lived
in the slums of New York.
And it was pretty
common for kids
to be bald back
then in the slums,
because that's how
you took care of lice.
The neatest thing
about the comic strip
is, that's where the term
"yellow journalism" came from.
MAN: I did not know that.
I forget the name
of the newspapers,
but it was Pulitzer's
paper and William
Randolph Hearst's newspaper.
And they were massively
competing against each other
for viewership.
Originally, the Yellow Kid
appears in Pulitzer's paper.
But since it was so popular,
Hearst poached the comic's
creator for his own paper.
So Pulitzer got
a new illustrator
and he started
publishing Yellow Kid.
Next thing you know, you had
two competing Yellow Kids.
So the public started
calling the papers
Yellow Kid newspapers.
Those two main
competing newspapers--
I mean, they would straight
up lie about stuff just
to get the viewership.
So eventually, sensationalized
news stories became
known as yellow journalism.
MAN: Interesting.
RICK: So you wanted to sell it.
I'm here to sell it today.
How much did you want for it?
I'm asking $750 for it.
RICK: [sighs] How did you
come up with the price 750?
I saw it, like, in a
price guide, I think,
that was about 10 years old.
RICK: [sighs] I mean,
my big problem is,
no one knows about this, OK?
I'll tell you what.
I'll give you $150 for it.
You might see a book that
gives you a price in it.
That means nothing if you can't
find anybody to pay that price.
We need to come
up a little bit.
$200, it's yours.
RICK: No.
I'll give you 175.
No one else is going to buy it.
No one else knows what it is.
I'm being a nice guy.
You could wait another
five or six years,
find someone else
that knows what it is.
175.
MAN: All right.
Sweet.
We got a deal.
Um, come up front and
we'll do some paperwork.
OK.
It's not as much as what
I was hoping to get today.
But I'm going to take this $175
and be bathing in $1 bills.